as a man now your the game has changed
in the game of chess sometimes it's not
about winning it's about making sure you
don't lose if you cannot lose if you
could not blunder any pieces and protect
your king long enough you'll win the
game and there's a lot of men who are
now like okay how do I not lose well you
know what I become [__] ruthless
that's how I don't lose I get I get all
my sex because the women are promiscuous
I get laid as much as I want I don't let
anyone [__] tie me into anything dumb
any [__] wants to get fresh to me or
[__] talk to another dude I cut her
off financially but man you just get
ruthless so you don't lose the game but
that's because the game's been rigged
against men so the harder you rig the
game against us the more ruthless we're
gonna have to be to compete and that's
it's unfortunate I'm not saying I have
the answers I'm just saying why men do
what they do